foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to a video
that I'm very excited to be making so on
October 11th I played as some of you may
know a 55-game blitz match with the
world champion Magnus Carlson on
chess.com Magnus has been playing more
frequently on chess.com and I had never
played Blitz with him before we had only
played bullet uh one minute chess on Lee
chess so this was my first opportunity
my first experience with Magnus Carlson
uh in Blitz we played it with a Time
control of three minutes per game no
increment and I performed a lot better
than I expected uh the final score was
24 and a half for me and 30 and a half
uh for Magnus so he won the match by six
points but I was able to keep it very
close throughout I was leading after the
first six games and I am more than happy
uh to lose to Magnus by only six points
in 55 games I I gave it everything I had
and it was one of the really I wouldn't
wouldn't be exaggerating if I said it
was one of the the best experiences of
my life I had an absolute blast we
played for five hours uh from about 7
P.M to midnight and I wasn't streaming I
did everything possible to focus as
intensely as I could and I thought that
my level of play overall was pretty high
so because I wasn't streaming uh I
decided to make a video where I go
through all of the highlights of the
match I'll show you the most memorable
moments from my perspective I'll show
you some of the really cool
opportunities that both of us missed and
I will show you some of magnus's most
impressive moments uh in the games where
he defeated me so I hope that this will
give you a sense of how the match went
uh and I hope that this will be more
interesting than just a video where I
let's say just go superficially go over
all 55 games that wouldn't be very
feasible instead I want to really hit on
the most exciting moments of the match
and hopefully you will be able to
extract some instructive value from this
video as well you know these moments are
going to vary some of them are tactical
others are positional they vary by
difficulty and you can also use this as
a kind of practicum you can pause before
I show you the solution uh to each
moment and you can try to solve it
yourself so I hope you you enjoy this
overview let's dig in without any
further Ado so
I'm going to divide this into three
sections I will start by showing you my
highlights from from the games that I
won then I'll show you a couple of
missed opportunities from both of us and
finally we will focus on a couple of
magnus's most impressive moments so he
ended up winning 25 times I won 19 times
and we made 11 draws of course not all
of my 19 wins were anything to be proud
of a lot of the time I had to resort to
dirty flagging I had a couple of really
lucky swindles but I did have a couple
of games where I really was able to
produce high quality chess and we are
going to start with the games that I was
white and the position in front of you
happened pretty early in the match so I
have the white pieces
and this is a very typical Karo Khan and
here Magnus makes a very natural move
that turns out to be the decisive
mistake he pushes the pawn to C5 if you
play the karagon you know that this is
perhaps the most common idea both in the
French and in the Karo Khan disrupting
and trying to undermine White's main
Central Pawn chain but the issue is that
black is insufficiently developed here
and I was able to pounce on that very
accurately so I noticed that the queen
on B6 is actually a lot more Awkward
than it looks I took on C5
Magnus recaptured with the Knight and
now Bishop E3 pins the Knight to the
queen now Magnus saw that and the Knight
isn't actually lost black has the move
Knight C6 opening up uh another defender
on the Knight and it doesn't seem like
white has any clear ways of reinforcing
the pressure on the Knight but this is
where I was able to find a really nice
idea I realized that if I could find a
way to open the C file I would be able
to bring my Rook to C1 and add pressure
to the Knight but that's a lot easier
said than done because this Pawn on C2
isn't going to go away on its own but
here's what I was able to find Bishop
comes out to B5 for starters pinning the
Knight on C6 and after Bishop E7 the
most important move of the entire
sequence Knight E1 to D3 this adds
another attacker but the point is it
forces black to take the Knight with the
bishop and after C takes D3 I have
achieved my goal of opening the C file
there's nothing that black can do about
this pin Magnus saw nothing better than
to Castle and now Rook C1 comes through
and it is decisive there are three
attackers on the night only two
Defenders and the only way that black
can save the piece is by pushing the
d-pawn up to D4 allowing me to take it
and after the trade I still have the pin
on the Knight I have an extra pawn and
I'm totally dominating on all three
sides of the board Magnus drops the
queen back to A7 to prepare to reinforce
the Knight but it's too little too late
I dropped the bishop back to E3 and
after B6 D4 I was able to win the game
in just a few more moves the Queen's
coming out to G4 whites up a pawn and
Black's position is in shambles so that
was a a little sequence that I was
pretty proud of and it was maybe one of
the smoothest games that I won moving on
to the second position so here once
again I'm playing White
and I am up let's see I'm up accounting
never been my Forte white is up two
pawns but it's not actually that easy to
make progress my king is relatively
unsafe the bishop is loose but what I
noticed is that my main asset in this
position is the battery that I have
built which is staring right at the G7
Pawn the issue is that the queen is
doing a great job of Defending that pawn
but we can change that when there's a a
large distance between uh a defending
piece and the thing that it's defending
that opens up the possibility of
interference tactics and white has a
classic interference idea here with the
move E5 it may look bad because it opens
up Black's Bishop but it's so much more
important to cut off the queen slice off
the queen and threaten Checkmate on G7
and the Queen off offside black just
doesn't have the necessary Firepower to
defend the king against the onslaught
the only way to defend G7 is to play the
move F5 Now The Rook defends the pawn
but as a result of F5 the G6 square has
been fatally weakened I gave a check on
G6 and now a very nice follow-up move H6
shattering the last remaining defense if
black takes the bishop then H takes G7
King G8 and queen E8 check is a simple
Checkmate after Queen h8
Magnus was forced to take on E5 in this
position
and now I did something I regret a
little bit I took on G7 and here I
decided to trade into a winning uh
Bishop end game up upon I took on G7 and
I won the end game pretty smoothly but
instead it would have been prettier and
more efficient to give a check on H6
King G8 is forced otherwise Queen f8 is
Checkmate and now white wins with Rook
to hg7 and queen takes C6 picking up the
bishop but in the game I traded
everything on G7 and I was able to win
by creating a second pass Pawn on the
queen side and Black's defenses here are
overwhelmed
okay so on we go to the next highlight
so once again I have the white pieces in
this game
and this as you can probably guess came
from a rue Lopez we had a lot of Rue
Lopez's with both colors Magnus was
regularly crushing me when he was on the
white side of the real Opus but when I
was on the white side I also was able to
produce a couple of nice games so in
this game I've managed to accumulate all
of my pieces on and assemble them on the
queen on the king side I've got my queen
my knight the two Rooks and the bishop
all staring at the F7 Pawn but I was
struggling to figure out how exactly to
transform that into something concrete
but then I discovered a really really
strong resource using the pin on the G6
Pawn the first move is Knight F5 check
this is very strong because the pawn on
D6 anchors Black's entire Center so
black has to eliminate this Knight but
now the pawn takes its place uh putting
tremendous pressure on the G6 Pawn
Magnus responds with G5 as it turns out
uh this was a mistake
and Magnus was hoping to lock up the
king side on the next move with F6 but I
didn't let him do that F6 check myself
locking the Knight out of the game
forcing the king onto a vulnerable
Square Magnus moves up to G6 and this
actually accelerates the defeat but the
reason I'm showing this game is this
next move that I made at first I was
getting nervous Magnus is a very hard
guy to Checkmate I could sense that
there was something that I couldn't find
what it was then I realized that the
problem is that the bishop is no longer
actively participating in the game I
noticed that the king is on a light
Square so if I could get the bishop onto
this diagonal that I've highlighted uh
B1 H7 then I'll be able to push the
d-pawn out of the way and the King will
be toast and once I made that
observation the move was really easy C3
in order to vacate the C2 Square for the
bishop is totally decisive bcbc and now
Magnus drops the king to H6 and now I
realize that apart from C2 I have an
even better Square for the bishop all
the way back to D1 forcing the queen in
back to G6 because if black plays Queen
H4 then I was planning to trade Queens
and play the quiet but totally deadly
move Rook q1 just look at Black's King
there is no way to stop this maneuver
Rook F5 Rook H5 resulting in ladder
Checkmate or black s to give away all of
his pieces so Magnus had to drop the
queen back to G6 and now another Strong
attacking move H4
trying to remove really the last
Defender if the G5 Pawn disappears
then the king is going to be checkmated
rook h8 and now Rook F5 increasing the
pressure on the G5 Pawn there are many
wins at this point but I was just happy
with the way that I attacked and now I
play the move E4 opening up the E3
Square for the queen which not only
results in Checkmate but also Forks The
Rook on A7 Magnus one Knight f8 of
course I can take the Rook if I want to
but instead I decided to win the game
with Rook G5 this traps the queen
because if the queen drops back to H7
there's a very nice checkmate with Rook
H5 Queen takes G4 and queen G5 so this
was one of my nicer one really one of my
only games where I managed to uh really
Checkmate magnus's King uh without
making too many big mistakes so those
were uh the highlights with the white
pieces there is one more highlight the
most memorable moment of the match for
me that I will get to at the end but for
now let's move to my highlights with the
black pieces and we will start with this
position so now I am playing laying
black and we had a lot of King's Indians
we had a lot of structures like this
where Magnus had pawns on e4 and C4 and
the reason that this structure usually
is very bad for black is because the
pawn on D6 is a massive weakness it's
backward and white correspondingly holds
complete dominance over the square in
front of the pawn the D5 square is a
nasty Outpost for whites Knight so I
knew that I had to do something or
Magnus was about to drag his his Knight
to D5 and that would be the end of me
and then I realized that the queen and
the Rook on D2 are on forkable squares
so the only thing that's preventing
Knight takes E4 is that pawn on F3 and
there comes the sacrifice Knight takes
F3 is the only way uh to stay in the
game King takes F3 now we take on e4
forking the queen and the Rook but after
Queen D3 the moment that I was most
proud of at first I was tempted to just
grab the Rook automatically but I
realized that after Rook takes D2 black
is actually borderline lost because the
Knight is still coming into D5 and it's
going to just Lord over the whole
position whitesnites are so much
stronger here than especially the d8
Rook which is just staring uh at the D6
pawn and doing nothing but I realized
that the pod on G3 is another hidden
weakness the queen on C7 is aiming at it
and hopefully this is making you realize
that I have the follow-up D5 opening up
a massive attack on the G3 Pawn white
has to defend it at all costs and so
Magnus played the move Knight F4 if
white takes on D5 and queen takes G3 is
a very Elementary Checkmate king itsu
queen G2 is just uh totally devastating
it's Unthinkable so Knight F4 happened
now and only now do I take the rook and
the point is that no matter which way
white takes if white takes with the Rook
I play the move D take C4 getting a
third Pawn for uh and The Rook for the
two knights and most importantly white
cannot recapture with the queen because
the Rook on D2 is hanging Magnus took
back with the queen I played DC4
he covered with the night my queen
dropped into E5 and at this point white
is already much much worse and I went on
to win the game the king is weak black
has three pawns and a rook for the two
knights and B takes C4 runs into Queen
E4 and queen takes E4 the Knight loses
its support and I was able to win by
doubling on the D file and ultimately
just winning one of magnus's knights
okay on we go to the next position so
most of the time throughout the match I
was getting soundly outplayed in the
opening with the black pieces I can
count probably on one hand the amount of
times that I was actually equal uh after
10 or 15 moves with black so I was doing
a lot of swindling I was doing a lot of
you know searching for cheap tactics in
bad positions and in this game I was
really able to find something that I was
proud of so clearly black is worse
why is black worst because white is a
massive space Advantage he's got these
two really monster Bishops especially
the dark squared Bishop which is
uncontested and these kingside pawns are
going to tear me apart if I don't do
something immediately so I knew that I
needed to produce some sort of counter
play against whites King but it's not
easy to do that because everything seems
to be defended what I noticed is that
the White Queen on D1 is actually
believe it or not overextended it's
doing two things at once it's protecting
G4 and it's protecting the Knight on D2
but way you might say isn't the H3 Pawn
protecting G4 as well it is but that
doesn't actually matter I was able to
find the only way to complicate the game
a bolt from the blue Bishop takes G4 now
the queen cannot take because the Knight
on D2 will be lost in Black wins a pawn
so H takes G4 is Forest and now comes
the point Knight takes the two forces
the queen out of the way and after Queen
takes G4 I get two pawns for the piece
and the white king is all of a sudden
wide open and it's always difficult to
adjust when you're dominating you're
positionally better and all of a sudden
you have to defend your king and Magnus
makes a couple of decisive errors here
that allow me to win the game in style
first he plays Rook F2 which is wrong
because it severs the connection between
the two Rooks and allows me to take on
B4 the only way to keep the advantage
according to the engine was the quiet
move Queen F2 but black has a lot of
stuff that he can do queen H5 check the
Knight could come into H4 so in a Blitz
game I would still think the black has
pretty decent chances but Magnus plays
Rook F2
I took on B4 and after a takes before I
would have traded on a one and I would
have given Perpetual check Queen H4
check King G1 Queen G3 check and here we
can see the point of trading that Rook
on A1 after Rook G2 we now have not
rookie one check which looks winning but
actually loses after Bishop F1 because
the queen is still hanging but rather we
play Queen E1 check forcing the queen
trade and simultaneously picking up the
bishop on A1 so for all of this to work
it is necessary to get rid of The Rook
that was on A1 and that is why Rook F2
is a mistake so after a b Magnus ended
up taking my knight on G6 I took back
that doesn't actually change the
combination a takes before uh would
still fail to that sequence in fact he
should have played a takes before and
after Queen H4 check white can force a
draw with King G2 and at this point
there's going to be a Perpetual check
but Magnus was still very ambitious and
so he plays Rook G2
I dropped the queen to H4 and take
another Pawn on A3 at this point I have
four pawns for the piece and what Magnus
probably missed is that he cannot take
back with the bishop due to the very
pretty Rook takes A3 and Rook E1 check
forces white to give up his Queen and
black as a gazillion pawns and the queen
uh for the two Rooks so after B takes A3
Magnus had to move the bishop away and
now I continue the attack with Rook E4
threatening to pick up two more of
White's pawns at this point white is
already lost his position is in shambles
and I was able to win the game pretty
quickly F5 doubling Rooks on E8 Magnus
plays F takes G6 one last chance going
after the G7 pawn and now I was really
happy with the com F6 locking the bishop
out of the equation and there are simply
too many threats on the queen side too
many pieces in the attack the game ended
after Queen H2 Queen F2 Queen H5 why
Queen H5 because that opens up the
pathway for the rook and now white has
no good way to stop all of the checks on
the back ranking F1 on Queen D1 and
Magnus resigned because after Bishop E1
I can win in a variety of ways but the
simplest and the prettiest move is a
rook F4 deflection sacrifice white
cannot refuse it because otherwise he
loses the queen after Queen F4 Queen
takes C1 is Checkmate so I thought this
was a nice example of uh turning around
a game that really went wrong in the
opening
okay so in the next position I was able
to find a very nice tactic this was
maybe my nicest uh combination of the
entire match this came at the very tail
end of the match I think this was the
fourth to last game or something like
that so I once again have the black
pieces here Magnus uh attempted a king
side attack that has misfired so I'm
currently up upon the pawn on G5 is
completely holding white at Bay it's
restricting the night but if you give
white time he's going to play H4 and
he's going to restart uh the the attack
on the king side especially if you can
open the H file so I knew that I had a
sense of urgency and I need to do
something on the other side of the board
well what exactly at first I thought
well maybe we can sack the Knight but
that doesn't really do anything because
black doesn't have enough pieces in the
attack but then I was able to discover a
really really pretty tactical sequence
that relies on a a nice mating pattern
so feel free to pause the video here
I'll take a sip of coffee and I'll let
you think about it
actually I'll pop the AC on just
thinking about playing with Magnus is
making me sweat
all right
so the move and once again the bolt from
the blue is Rook takes C3 now this is a
pretty typical sacrifice in these types
of positions but what on Earth is the
follow-up after B takes C3 well now the
Knight drops in for a visit on A2 and
where a lot of people you know would
stop calculating is after King B2 it
looks like white not only has the extra
exchange but now the Knight is trapped
on top of it but the Crux of the
combination is the move Knight takes C3
eliminating a critical Defender after
King C3 Queen drops into B4 with Shaq
man I really really like this mating
pattern this would actually be Checkmate
without the Knight The Rook the bishop
and all of the pawns except E4 and A5
you just see how strong of an attacker
The Queen Is So rewinding to Knight A2
check Magnus went the other way but that
doesn't change anything I still take on
C3 of course he did not take my knight
but that still allows my queen to drop
into before for setting up a decisive
threat of a discover check White's King
is caught on the crossfire
and the game ended in pretty mundane
fashion we traded on D7 Magnus went
Queen A1 setting one last trap and it
was really amazing uh how I know this is
a cliche but the level of resilience
that he demonstrated in situations where
I thought all right it's made it's got
to be made in a couple of moves Magnus
made me find every last accurate move
and in many cases it allowed him to turn
the game around but here I remained on
top rather than making an impulsive move
like Knight takes A4 which allows white
to cover it with C3 I made the patient
move Rook C8 adding another attacker and
this turns out to be decisive King E1
Magnus makes a Mad Dash for the king
side but uh Horrors await him there as
well Knight B1 check I always like
putting my piece on the initial
development square of my opponent's
piece always feels badass this of course
sets up Queen D2 in the event of King D1
so he went the other way but after Rook
takes C2 King G3 Queen D6 he resigned
because at this point white has to give
up all of of his pieces in order to
avoid checkmate
okay so those were my highlights with
the black pieces and I have saved one
last highlight which I think represents
uh the most memorable moment of the
whole match for me the moment that I'll
be telling my grandkids about and
there's a there's a story behind this
highlight so in 2010 I played a
tournament in France called the Capel La
Grande open it's a very big open
tournament I was 23 50 at the time I was
a few day master and one of the things
the tournament is known for is that it
has what's called accelerated pairings
so normally as a 2300 you would Play
Down in the first round I would play
like a 1900 but in Capella Grande you
you know the 2300s are already playing
grand Masters in the first round and I
was paired with uh very strong French
Grandmaster jean-mark to grave uh High
2500s former French champion and I was
super super jet lagged because I had
arrived from the West Coast the day
before I didn't have high expectations
for the game uh but of course those are
precisely the moments when you tend to
perform the best and so I did I managed
to win the game and I won it in really
memorable fashion I've shown Snippets of
this game on stream before I won't go
through the whole game I'll show you the
pertinent moments so to my surprise my
opponent played the philidor I was like
okay Bishop C4 Bishop E7 D4 this is all
Mainline stuff I'm going to fast forward
to uh the critical moment so we played
all of the normal theoretical moves at
this point I was out of book so I didn't
know what the main continuation was and
after a little bit of thought I was able
to find a a really interesting idea
this is called the Rubinstein maneuver
named after Akiba Rubenstein one of the
strongest players of the early 20th
century uh who really developed this
maneuver and this is a maneuver that
involves bringing your queen to the A2
or H2 Square which can be done for a
variety of reasons in this case what it
does is builds a battery that
intensifies the pressure on F7 and my
opponent was you know pretty surprised
at this very unconventional move it was
a novelty it's never been played before
or since and he did not react very well
he pushed my Bishop away to G3 then he
went Knight H5 I brought my queen up to
A2 setting up an attack on F7 and here
we come to the critical moment black
plays Queen F6 this is a good move it
attacks the Knight it defends F7 and I
automatically dropped my knight back to
F3 this was just an autopilot move what
I forgot is that the Knight isn't
actually hanging hopefully you've
realized that it's not hanging because
if black takes it we take on F7 and we
win The Rook on E8 and so white doesn't
have to worry about the knight at all
instead said white can concern himself
with dislodging the queen from F6 and
the opportunity that I missed here was
the very strong move Rook E1 to E3 this
is a classic Rook lift and it turns out
that black is a very hard time stopping
the move Rook F3 which of course would
come with great effect uh the engine
indicates that the only way to preserve
a playable position is to move the
Knight into F4 but still after Knight D
to E2 trying to dislodge the Knight
white gets a very big initiative so I
was bummed about missing rookie 3 but I
ended up playing Knight F3 and I still
won the game you can find this game
online I also had a chess.com article
where I analyze it I'll probably put it
in the description but that's outside
the scope of what I'm talking about now
the crazy thing is that I had a game of
Magnus in which he also played the
filador and this was the only time in
the match or I think one of several
times in the match where Magnus played
the Philadelphia and for the first
couple of games I was responding with
the conventional D4 but then I
remembered that 13 years ago I played a
game where I decided on the secondary
main line which is Bishop C4 so I
decided to play it and Magnus goes
Bishop B7 and at this point I started
feeling you know butterflies in my
stomach because we're following the
exact course of my game with degrave and
I was like am I really going to get a
chance to use the exact same idea and
maybe I'll even be able to win the game
how crazy would that be so Watch What
Happens rookie 8 Bishop G5 so this is a
slight deviation from the degrave game
where actually is it a deviation let me
check where we deviated so here I have a
rook on E1 the bishop is on f8 and here
okay so Magnus didn't play the move A5
he saved a Tempo on that instead he
played H6 and here I dropped back to F4
rather than H4 but those are
insignificant differences Bishop f8
rookie one Knight bd7 the position is
very similar and you will never guess
what move I made in this position it is
indeed Queen B1 and it's not even like a
move recommended by the engine it was
just so cool to be able to exploit the
same idea but the story the plot
thickens Watch What Happens he plays
Knight E5
I dropped the bishop back Knight G6
dropped the other Bishop back
Knight H5 Queen A2 and I was like wait a
second my opponent in that game did
something almost identical he played
Knight H5 and now Magnus goes Queen F6
and 12 years later I was finally able to
use the analysis from the game against a
grave rather than autopiloting Knight F3
I was able to execute the idea that I
missed in that game I played the move
rookie three Magnus grabs the bishop on
G3 and now Rook e32 F3 I don't recapture
the Knight instead I go right after the
F7 Pawn
now and I felt I felt really really like
a badass and I was blitzing these moves
out because these aren't normally moves
that I would find instantly but it just
shows the benefits of analyzing every
one of your games you never know when
you can extract and apply the lessons
that you learn now what spoils the party
a little bit is that Rook F3 actually
isn't sound black has a crazy computer
defense that gives him the advantage
Magnus was unable to find it in a Blitz
game I'm sure he would be able to find
it in a classical game so in the game
Magnus already makes the decisive
mistake he covers with his other Knight
and now I'm able to take on G3 and uh
you can't take on D4 once again because
if Bishop takes F7 Magnus plays D5
trying to intercept uh this battery but
after Rook F4 Queen D4 he has walked
into another Discovery e takes D5 is
totally decisive Queen D2 dc6 I'm
already two puns up I'm winning a third
Pawn because black can't defend F7 and
B7 at the same time and I went on to win
the game pretty smoothly now for those
who are really looking for a challenge
you can pause the video and try to see
uh if you can figure out the defense for
black and I'm not just looking for one
move I'm looking primarily for the
follow-up move
so the correct move is Knight G3 to F5
and this is pretty logical on the
surface but it appears that after Knight
takes F5 there is just no way in hell to
stop all of these threats in Knight H6
Bishop F7 how do you prevent uh the
pressure on the f-file from becoming
decisible it turns out that the
cold-blooded follow-up move is Knight G6
to E5 when you're trying to deal with a
discovered attack or a discovered check
normally what you want to try to do is
attack the tail of the discovery the
piece that's actually doing the
attacking that is usually the best way
to dismantle a discovered attack
mechanism and this is exactly what
happens here The Rook is attacked so if
the Knight doesn't move away with check
black simply takes the Rook with check
if white plays Knight takes H6 check and
Bishop takes F7 check it looks very
strong but if you keep calculating after
King h8 Bishop E8 takes takes white is
up two pawns yes but the king is in
shambles and more importantly Bishop E6
picks up the bishop on E8 it's simply a
double attack against that Queen which
some genius positioned on A2
so instead white can try uh the really
cool move Bishop takes F7 check this is
such a sexy move but even this move
doesn't work now what's the point of
Bishop F7 well if black recaptures with
the Knight now white plays Knight takes
H6 check the queen is attacked so the
queen has to take and queen takes F7
picks up the Rook on E8 white is winning
you also don't want to take on F7 with
the queen because Knight takes H6 check
also picks up the queen black gets a lot
of pieces for it the position is
approximately balanced so instead black
makes the ridiculously cold-blooded move
King h8 allowing white to take the Rook
black recaptures on F3 and after she
takes F3 another cold-blooded move
Bishop B6 currently white is up two
Pawns in a piece but you're losing the
piece back and white is actually much
worse here because well because the King
on G1 is in shambles it's uh in a
terrible spot and the Knight on F5 is uh
immobile because you're going to lose
the pawn on F3 if you move it away if
you don't move it away black is going to
take twice on F5 with a massive attack
on White's King so this was a little bit
disappointing but I wanted to point this
out and you know for the sake of
completeness nonetheless this was a
really memorable moment where I was able
to directly apply this idea uh that I
didn't play all those years ago in my
game against the grave so
um my memories in the philidor against
the Philadelphia are very positive and
those were the highlights from my wins
next I have two
uh highlights uh on both of our ends
from opportunities that we missed both
of us missed several opportunities
throughout the games to produce uh
really really nice sequences I'm going
to show you one missed opportunity for
Magnus and One Missed opportunity for me
and then we'll move on to uh to magnus's
victories which I know is what
everybody's looking forward to anyway so
the first missed opportunity is on
magnus's end this was I think game four
or game five of the match I had the
black pieces and actually let's flip the
board because we'll be looking at this
from magnus's perspective so at first
sight it may seem that white is easily
winning because he's got the Piggies on
the seventh but Rooks on the seventh can
don't always lead to Checkmate and this
is an example of that where white can
check as long as he wants but you can't
Checkmate The King The King has three
Escape squares and you can only cover
two of them at the same time so there's
no way to Checkmate directly and the
additional problem is that I have this
little boy on D3 tree that is pulling
White's attention in all sorts of places
so it appears that if white plays a
nonchalant move like for example Rook
takes H6 I will intercept the other Rook
with Rook D5 and it appears that
actually if anybody is winning it's
black actually white can repeat moves
here with Rook G6 and Rook H6 but if
white takes on D5 then he is losing both
of these pawns cover the D file and
white is not in time Rook D6 D2 Rook
takes D5 and rookie one very important
that this is a check if White's King had
been on H2 this would have been working
D1 Queen and black ends up upper Rogue
so both of us had calculated this line
we were getting low on time and
ultimately Magnus decides to repeat
moves he goes Rook G7 Rook F7 and we
made a drop but the amazing thing Hikaru
pointed this out on his stream he was
covering the first half of the match on
his stream which I really really
appreciated so Hikaru found this
brilliant idea Rook takes H6 Rook D5 is
correct now white makes
a ridiculous looking move Rook back to
H7
so this connects the Rooks once again on
the seventh rank but doesn't black just
play D2 and doesn't white now absolutely
have to force a draw by checking on the
seventh rank well as it turns out white
is winning Rook G7 checking f8 and now
there is a ridiculous move that's almost
impossible to spot in Blitz pause the
video see if you can find it
so the move that both of us missed is H6
I love tactics that involve allowing
your opponent to promote with check how
crazy is it that after King H2 black
doesn't have a single a single good a
single effective check and it's
precisely because the pawn on G2 and the
pawn on G4 are doing such a good job of
fully limiting the power of the queen
and of course the Rook if the G4 Pawn
wasn't on the board the Queen would be
able to swing back to H5 if the G2 Pawn
was missing well then obviously black
would have a second ranked check as it
stands there's simply no way to stop
Rook h a check white black just has to
give away all his pieces uh and then get
checkmated on h8 so I really thought
this was a brilliant idea and once again
something I'm positive Magnus would spot
in a classical game but you know with 30
seconds on the clock you know one cannot
expect anybody to find something like
this now we get to my missed opportunity
this one really really stung because I
realized I had this right after I made
the wrong move so I played a Karo Khan
with black I got a nice position a
knight on e4 and I could sense that I
probably had some play against White's
King but the thing is when you're
playing Magnus and I experienced this
during the match uh you're second
guessing yourself all the time like
every move that I see like Magnus must
have seen that it must be wrong and that
really messes with your brain sometimes
I was trying to be as confident as
possible most of the time I was trusting
my instincts but here I I trusted him
and I made a non-descript move I don't
remember what I played I think I played
Queen to E7 or something like that and I
missed a relatively straightforward
crushing tactic once again you know the
drill pause the video see if you can
improve on my play I'll finish off the
coffee
I didn't have much remaining anyway so
the move is Bishop D6 takes G3 caprau
just banging through the king side and
of course after H takes G3 another
follow-up stack Rook takes G3 really
illustrates the power of the queen
Knight tandem white has to take black
takes back on G3 and it's actually just
check made in three moves King F1 black
isn't even messing around first you take
the Knight with check
if King E2 then check and mate on uh
with a pawn and if white goes the other
way then it's all very simple another
check on G3 and either Knight or queen
F2 is made depending on where the King
goes and it's really as simple as that
of course technically the best move for
white according to the engine is King to
H1 here but I'm pretty sure I would have
been able to win the game after Bishop
takes H2 so this one hurt and after I
lost this game I went on a bit of a uh a
tilts and lost a couple in a row so
these were two opportunities that both
of us missed and now we get to magnus's
Highlights now once again Magnus won the
match he played better than me but since
I'm making a video for my end I did
select more of my highlights than
magnus's highlights but that's not to
suggest uh that Magnus didn't play an
incredible match he played tons of
brilliant games and a lot of his wins
were very much in boa constrictor
fashion you got a better position out of
the opening and he didn't even give me a
chance but Bang this also had a couple
of tactical highlights and plenty of
moments to choose from so I have
selected one two three four of uh four
of four moments that really stuck with
me as an example of what makes Magnus uh
such a ridiculously amazing universally
amazing player and we'll start with this
position and we will face
this with from magnus's side
so I'm playing white he's got the black
pieces here and uh I made a mistake
early on in the opening but I managed to
recover I won a piece and this is the
moment where I thought I was out of the
woods my king on F1 is clearly unsafe
but if black just gives a check on F6
the king is able to run into the corner
King G2 Rook F2 King H1 and black is no
clear follow-up furthermore white
threatens a Checkmate on C8 because the
bishop is covering the Luft Square on H7
always an important thing uh to to
recognize Magnus started thinking and I
could sense that I was probably going to
win the game then he plays the move H5
very cryptic H5 what is he doing well
obviously I realized that I shouldn't
play Queen F5 or queen F4 because that
runs into the pin but I didn't see a
reason a compelling reason not to take
the pawn on H5 well Magnus did see a
compelling reason and I was made aware
of this reason very shortly
Rook F6 check
King G2 Queen F2 check this is what I
had missed I was assuming that he was
going to check on F2 with the Rook no
the queen gives the check after King H1
Rook H6 reveals the reason for playing
H5 the queen is skewered to the H2 pawn
and all I can do is give up my queen I
tried the move Rook F1 counter-attacking
black screen but the very elegant Queen
takes F1 ends the game it's a classic
Desperado sack and I resigned because
after Bishop F1 Rook H5 black is up in
exchange and upon there is nothing left
to play for so the answer is no I should
not have taken the pawn instead I should
have dropped my queen back to E2 uh
maintaining a very double edged position
okay so next a very pretty tactical
sequence from late in the match this was
another one of the uh maybe the 50th
game or so this was honestly just a
brilliant game all around you can find
this in my game archive if you want to
see the whole thing but I'll just show
you uh the very pretty ending Magna says
the white pieces he just went right
after my king from right out of the gate
and here he demonstrates uh an
incredible combination that caps the
attack off the first thing you might see
is the move Queen H6 check and this does
keep a decisive Advantage white should
be able to convert the attack but there
is a more effective and nicer way to win
there's Checkmate in six moves let's see
if you can spot it
foreign
so the key is to realize that whenever
there's a queen on the f file and a rook
on the H file like this there is a
common tactical Motif that involves
deflo not Quinn H6 that involves
deflecting the King by sacking The Rook
opening up the F7 Square for the queen
and driving the king out into the open
King h8 gets mated with Rook H1 so I had
to play King H6 still Rook H1 the king
is driven further out into the
Wilderness the queen picks up the Knight
with check King has to move into F4 and
queen drops back to F6 with Checkmate
this is a very nice mating sequence
and this was an all-around brilliant
attacking game
okay
so
actually I want to save this one for
last I have two more Magnus highlights
to show you there were so many segments
uh in the match where I just felt like I
was playing somebody who was inhabiting
another mental Universe like by the time
I you know finished putting my clothes
in the morning he he had discovered all
the secrets of the position and there
were stretches of like 5-10 moves that
were like all engine moves it was
honestly stunning the accuracy with
which Magnus handles complicated
positions and this is a great example of
that so he's got the white pieces here
and it's pretty clear that white is
better right White's got a nice night on
G5 my king isn't very safe but I was
putting my pinning my hopes on you know
these very nicely placed Knights on C5
and D5 and in this position Magnus
initiates a ridiculously accurate
sequence he makes you know six engine
moves in a row and just destroys me he
starts with a natural move C4 this
chases the Knight out of D5 and most
importantly if the Knight drops back to
C7 The Rook drives into F6 super
unpleasant doesn't move preparing to
double on the f file this is totally
lost for black so I decided to cover the
F4 Square by night but now another Super
accurate move Bishop D4 to E3 this
attacks the Knight and forces it back
toward the corner the Knight has no
squares except H5 and now comes the
cherry on top the pawn runs into G4
harassing this poor Knight yet again
if the Knight would have dropped back to
G7 white would have repurposed these
pawns as battering rams H5 decides the
game because the attack on G6 is
unbearable a funny line is Queen E8 and
now H6 not the only winning move but it
simply traps the Knight on G7 isn't that
crazy how he just tracks my knight all
throughout the board so Knight G7 being
not an option I decided to take the
plunge and play Knight G3 this attacks
The Rook so he trades in this position
one last Super accurate move by Magnus
how do you actually attack this Knight
well I was hoping that Magnus was going
to do it with his Queen this would be a
very serious mistake because I had
intended H6 counter-attacking whitesnite
and the best that white can do is win
upon if the Knight drops back then I can
now safely move my knight back to E4 or
defend it with the other night night ce4
but rather than playing Queen G2 he
plays King G2 this is what I had missed
the queen is kept on C2 for a very
specific reason and that reason is
revealed when I played H6 6 otherwise
the night is lost and all of a sudden
Queen comes in and captures the G7 the
G6 bond that is why you had to keep the
queen on C2 after Queen G7 trade and the
final move of the game is Bishop takes
C5 eliminating the other Knight and
after Knight takes C6 check I resigned
the irony of this game is that after
Knight takes f8 I have lost all of my
pieces except the original Knight that
he was trying to trap I think there's a
certain Elegance to that I resigned
after after Knight takes C6 check so
just a a really impressive stretch for a
three minute game Remember the Time
control is three plus zero and the final
highlight is is really just a incredibly
sexy move that Magnus made in one of the
games from the middle of the match
so he's got white in this position uh he
is up a pawn but we were both in acute
time pressure here and I decided to
Spring a devilish trap I played the move
H6 now it appears that I am voluntarily
parting ways with the bishop on C5 but
obviously someone like Magnus is not
going to miss any Elementary tactics
even with two seconds on the clock it
was crazy how quickly he saw through all
of my dirty tricks Queen takes E5 runs
into the classic Rook D1 check another
deflection tactic if you take you lose
the queen and if you don't take well you
actually can't move the king up to H2
but you can block with a knight but here
I take on C1 simultaneously defending
the queen on C7 so
okay well we get why white can't take on
C5 but how does white actually reinforce
the threat of Knight takes of Queen
takes C5 it's not so easy to stop this
idea of Rook D1 and Magnus finds the
best engine move the only way to
directly win this bishop and it is it's
an incredible move I'll uh encourage you
to pause the video One Last Time and see
if you can figure it out
no more coffee
okay well it's a retreating night move
those are the hardest moves to find
Knight F3 drops back to G1 preemptively
in order to ensure that Rook D1 does not
come with chat
now the bishop is attacked and that's
not the end of the story I can defend
the bishop with Rook D5 and I was still
hopeful here but now he follows up with
E4 The Rook is attacked and it's got two
squares E5 and G5 and the same move uh
ensues after both of these moves I
played Rook G5 the Knight walks back to
F3 this is what makes the sequence so
elegant Now The Rook is out of squares
on the fifth rank I had to play Rook
takes G4 and queen takes E5 picks up the
bishop and wins the game the same would
have happened after rookie 5 Knight F3
notice that after Rook takes C4 Queen
takes C5 the Knight is defending the E1
Square so rookie one check no longer
works naichi one is such an incredible
move made all the more Amazing by the
fact that he had exactly 30 seconds and
it took him three seconds to find the
move Knight you won in this position so
those are but a few of magnus's
highlights and uh that concludes this
highlight presentation I hope you've
enjoyed this overview of of the match
I was agonizing for a while over what
exact how what exactly the video should
look like but I'm pretty happy with how
it came out I think I was able to hit on
the most memorable points once again I
lost the match by six points the final
score was 24 and a half 30 and a half
but I was really happy with the way that
I played uh there were some dirty Flags
but overall I played my best chess and
it you know of course needless to say is
a great honor uh to face Magnus in such
a long match it's it's a match that I'll
remember for a long time and I'm hoping
for a rematch sometime soon and on that
note ladies and gentlemen I'm going to
pause the video here hope you enjoyed
and uh I hope to see you in another one
of these highlight videos pretty soon
thank you and goodbye
foreign
[Music]